ich finde die diskussion wird so ein
bisschen als wenn wir gerade darüber
entscheiden ob wir neue in die
atomenergie für die nächsten 200 jahre
einsteigen also der atommüll ist da das
ist ein problem das es gibt und ich
glaube dass der diskussionspunkt er ist
streiten wir uns über zehn jahre weiter
atommüll oder streiten wir sogar 15 grad
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen bei 310
fragen wir starten direkt mit der
konflikt frage ist der deutsche
atomausstieg ein fehler wenn ihr sagt ja
der ist ein riesenspieler sogar dann
geht er ins grüne feld und wenn ihr sagt
nein der ausstieg ist genau richtig so
je schneller desto besser dann geht er
jetzt bitte aufs gelbe fällt ihr könnt
euch jetzt gerne positionieren
[Musik]
zu gefährlich zu umweltschädlich zu
teuer nach der atomkatastrophe in
fukushima im jahr 2011 ist der
atomausstieg in deutschland beschlossene
sache ende 2022 soll nun das letzte
atomkraftwerk bei uns vom netz gehen
endlich jubeln die einen die teilweise
jahrzehntelang gegen atomkraft in
deutschland protestiert haben aber warum
denn gerade jetzt sagen die anderen die
wie die meisten europäischen länder
davon überzeugt sind nur mit atomkraft
können wir das klima retten und kürzlich
attestiert er dann auch noch die
eu-kommission
atomenergie ist grün zumindest solange
wir nicht genug erneuerbare energien
haben meine gäste bei 310 fragen sind
sich uneinig aber wir sind ja auch hier
um einen kompromiss zu finden und ich
bin wirklich sehr gespannt ob sich die
beiden seiten heute ein bisschen
aufeinander zu bewegen werden denn eins
ist klar alle menschen die hier heute
auf dem spielfeld stehen die wollen den
klimawandel stoppen die frage ist eben
nur wie deswegen die frage an euch mit
atomenergie oder ohne wo würdet ihr dann
auf dem feld stehen bei grün
der deutsche atomausstieg ist ein
riesenfehler oder bei gelb nein das
genau richtig so und soll wird er so
schnell es geht passieren
für euch meine gäste gilt ab jetzt wenn
ihr der anderen seite in einem argument
zustimmt dann könnt ihr einen schritt
auf sie zugehen und wenn euch etwas
aufregt ein argument eine aussage was
auch immer dann könnt ihr auch das gerne
mit einer bewegung von deutlichen indem
ihr einen schritt nach hinten geht alina
ich möchte mit dir anfangen ich glaube
bei vielen von uns haben sich die bilder
aus tschernobyl wahrscheinlich für immer
ein geprägt vor allem durch die medien
durch serien durch fotos wie ist das für
dich woran denkst du wenn du tschernobyl
hörst du hast ja auch eine ganz
persönliche ganz persönlichen bezug dazu
also tatsächlich tschernobyl ist eine
familiengeschichte für mich ich bin
selber aus tschernobyl evakuiert und
mein vater hatte an des tags des an der
nachts des gaus in tschernobyl kraftwerk
gearbeitet und auch jahren später ist
sagen dann nach dem von tschernobyl
katastrophe gestorben trotz meine
persönliche bezug zu tschernobyl ich bin
generell gegen deutsche ausstieg aus dem
atom programm ich glaube dass
atomenergie ist viel grüner und
[Musik]
zuverlässig zuverlässiger als viele
denken und ich glaube auch das war eine
populistische und zu frühe entscheidung
von deutsche regierung untersteht ist
wahrscheinlich auf der seite des feldes
wo einige sich darüber wundern würden
magst du das noch mal erklären warum die
eben da stehst und nicht auf der
gegenseite also ich verstehe das was
passiert ist in tschernobyl ist ein
riesiger katastrophe und wie gesagt
meine familie wurde dadurch direkt
beeinflusst andererseits ich bin eine
realistin ich kann sehen wir statistisch
manche sachen passieren oder nicht
passieren wie gefährlich irgendwas ist
im vergleich zu die andere sachen und im
realität es ist eigentlich eine von sich
aus sichersten
energiequellen was heutzutage gibt also
wenn der umwelt konventionelle energien
hier bewegen sich schon ein paar leute
nach hinten zu viel du hast dich auch
ein bisschen nach hinten bewegt kannst
du verstehen warum alina auf dem
aufsteller grünen seite des feldes steht
eine art gesagt sie ist realistin aber
ich bin da realist sein ist einfach
anzuerkennen dass sie sich technologie
zu gefährlich ist und zwar nicht nur
wegen raubes und tschernobyl man sagt ja
das war in der sowjetunion dann sagt man
versuche ich war ja da gab es ein 2 also
ich selbst kommen aus frankreich und dem
jubilar ja das ist bei bordeaux und da
hat vor 20 jahren zum beispiel eine
beinahe katastrophe gegeben weil
gleichzeitig ein sturm waren eine
überschwemmung von der gesamten
elektronischen anlage die die das akw
steuert wir waren sehr knapp
wie oft muss erst noch passieren nachdem
atomkraft herzen weil es einfach um sehr
wie das klima um unsere lebensgrundlage
geht wenn wir die zerstören wenn wir
nicht weiterleben und bei atomkraft
spiel sehr viel mit einer rolle es gibt
die atomare verseuchungen natürlich ein
problem ist aber auch die politischen in
stabilen welt ich mache jetzt gerade
hören wir gerade von ukraine und die
interessen russlands großmann ist eine
atommacht das ist nicht ungefährlich
also für mich können wir diese gefahren
nicht wahr und dann einfach ihr lehrer
du bist auch einen kleinen schritt nach
hinten gegangen warum
also ich habe mich gerade vor allem auch
an dem das wäre eine sichere
energiequelle gestoßen weil ich dachte
es gibt
alternativen die sind auf jeden fall
sicherer erneuerbare energien und wenn
menschen sagen atomenergie super sicher
und so toll da wird dabei vor allem auch
der uranabbau ab ausgeblendet wo große
teile von der natur zerstört werden und
so krankheiten in den abbaugebieten
immens in die höhe gehen krankheiten wie
krebs leukämie und so weiter und der
protest der an diesen orten
stattfindet der wird komplett ignoriert
dass für die atomenergie gewinnung
notwendige uran wird vor allem in
ländern des globalen südens und auf dem
territorium von indigenen gemeinschaften
abgebaut menschen die an atomkraft
festhalten blenden sowohl die kolonialen
kontinuitäten als auch die
gesundheitliche gefährdung die mit der
nutzung von atomkraftwerken einher geht
aus ersten schritt auf elia zugegangen
warum ich glaube das ist genau der
knackpunkt also es geht hier glaube ich
gar nicht darum zu sagen dass atomkraft
die mit abstand beste lösung dafür ist
wie wir unsere wir unseren strom
versichern aber ich glaube der zeitpunkt
zu diskutieren was ist richtig und was
falsch ist zeigt die falsche diskussion
für mich gibt es nicht die perfekte
lösung für die energiewende weil ich
glaube dass wir zu viele fehler in der
vergangenheit gemacht haben zum beispiel
sind wir zu früh aus der atomenergie
ausgestiegen und haben auch die
bettenzahl stück führt das heißt am ende
starten wir nicht von neuer sondern
müssten jetzt mit kompromissen arbeiten
das ist glaube ich außer frage dass
strahlung und dass atomkraftwerke ein
gewisses risiko haben aber auch rein
wissenschaftlich in den letzten jahren
durchaus klar ist dass atomkraftwerke
ein gewisses risiko haben dass der
einschätzbar ist und dafür kontrolle
erfolgt also von den leuten die daran
arbeiten den werte täglich gemessen
werden bis hin zu der entsorgung dem
prozess und wer davon betroffen es ist
also keine verdeckten prozess und ich
glaube da muss man andocken zu sagen wie
viel risiko man im kauf und was ist
sozusagen die kosten davon wenn man das
jetzt sofort abschaltet was passiert
dann also ich finde hier muss man sich
schon auch fragen wo werden denn die
risiken in kauf genommen und in
deutschland gibt es uranvorkommen und in
deutschland wird uran nicht abgebaut
weil es extreme gesundheitliche schäden
nach sich zieht und weil dadurch die
natur zerstört wird und hier werden halt
die negativen folgen von uran abbau von
der atomindustrie ausgelagert vor allem
in den globalen süden also es geht darum
was ist richtig und was falsch und wie
geht es immer auch um menschenrechte das
ist auch wieder eine sehr eurozentrische
klima aktivistische sicht denn es ist
durchaus etwas was auch in anderen
kontinenten sowohl im asiatischen raum
als auch im amerikanischen
südamerikanischen raum auch ausgebaut
würden jetzt zu sagen das ist so dass
man das rein darauf unterbrechen kann
das sind europa seinen atommüll oder
sagen die schäden davon nur der globale
süden trägt ist er auch ein
gegenargument automatisch wenn wir hier
weiter auf atomenergie setzen würden die
kohle jetzt auswählen will keiner 15
grad risiken mehr hätten dann würde er
gewann 7 jetzt auch nicht schon so unter
der klimakrise leiden wäre es tut also
ich glaube das ist ein teufelskreis
wusste ich darum geht wer sich zum wäre
es falsch sondern was in den nächsten
schritte um den nächsten zehn jahren zu
also 15 grad zu schaffen also
davon so wie ich denke wir sind hier in
einer art
deutschsprachigen insel wenn man so will
wenn man tatsächlich um die grenzen
hinaus schaut mich nur in europa es
werden neue kernkraftwerke gebaut und
zwar genau in ländern des südens weil
sie eine sichere energie die versorgung
brauchen und sie wollen dass auch
günstig haben es werden welche gebaut in
bangladesch beispielsweise in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten wird das
gemacht und die werden sehr viel früher
klimaneutral sein als wir ich bin gegen
den ausstieg aus der kernenergie weil
das unweigerlich zu mehr fossile
verbrennung führen wird also mehr kohle
und gas und das heißt eine milliarde
tonnen mehr co2-emissionen bis 20.45
betrachtet ist eigentlich die atomkraft
auch den niedergang jetzt haben wir zum
beispiel gerade ein konflikt in der
ukraine wo ich mir sehr gut
atomkraftwerke sind weder für wetter-
extreme im rahmen der klimakrise in noch
eben für mögliche anschläge ausgelegt
das ist
gefährlich das ist einfach nicht wahr
also die kernkraftwerke sind für unfälle
ausgelegt es war genau das problem in
fukushima gewesen dass durch treffliches
nach dem nachlassen der behörden dort
und von tepco auch die nicht für den
schlimmsten fall vorgesorgt haben wenn
dort zum beispiel auch wie in
deutschland die kernkraftwerke auf den
schlimmsten event denen es in 10.000
jahren gibt vorbereitet gewesen wären
dann wäre das nicht passiert was in
fukushima passiert ist das muss man sich
klar machen dass ist nicht übertragbar
wie es frau kanzlerin merkel gemacht hat
auf deutschland das ist einfach nicht so
egal was sind denn deiner meinung nach
die schlimmsten gefahren an atomenergie
also einmal auf jeden fall auch dass es
keine möglichkeit gibt die abfälle
sicher zu verwahren denn die strahlen
eine million jahre und eine million
jahre kann es nirgendwo einen ort geben
wo die sicher sind es wird im zuge der
klimakatastrophe zu mehr stark
wetterereignissen kommen zum beispiel
überschwemmungen und so weiter das
bedeutet lagerorte sind noch mehr
also noch mehr gefährdet irgendwie
kaputt zu gehen oder nicht sicher zu
sein und dazu nochmals zu betonen wir
sind eben die risiken von vom uranabbau
wo niemand bock drauf hat also wer hat
er die lust irgendwo zu leben wo die
krebsraten mega nach oben gehen wer hat
lust das trinkwasser verunreinigt wird
also niemand und es gibt ja alternativen
erneuerbaren
die all diese problematiken und gefahren
eben nicht mit sich tragen auch sie
übrigens genauso weil sie genauso extra
aktiv verschiedene elemente aus der erde
rausholen müssen das ist nicht nichts
spezielles für uran das müssen wir
allgemein angehen wir müssen allgemein
dafür sorgen dass überall wo egal was
geborgen wird dass das richtig gemacht
wird und da gebe ich vollkommen zu wenn
es da mischt er gibt müssen wir dieses
natürlich bekämpfen aber das hat nichts
spezifisch mit uran zu tun das passiert
in vielen anderen bereichen auch jasmin
denkst du denn die punkte die elia
gerade angesprochen hat sind dass
risiken die wir einfach eingehen müssen
um das klima zu retten unter anderem
weil ich finde die diskussion wird so
ein bisschen als wenn wir gerade darüber
entscheiden ob wir neue in die
atomenergie für die nächsten 200 jahre
einsteigen also der atommüll ist da das
ist ein problem das es gibt und
retrospektiv auch die debatte darum wie
sehr in deutschland geforscht wird also
das wurde hier gerade schon angesprochen
die die forschung in atommüll in atom
prinzipiell in deutschland ist viel
eingeschränkter als es im ausland ist
und das führt dazu dass die debatte hier
auch bezüglich wie wir diesen müll denen
wir übrigens haben und chemischen seit
60 jahren über 60 jahre haben den
entfernen auch in den schatten stellen
das ist also sozusagen das koppelt sich
genau daran und ich glaube das ist es
viel größere problem jetzt zu sagen wenn
atomkraftwerke wir reden jetzt auch in
deutschland wirklich nur noch von jetzt
glaube ich zwei stück die was eine drei
stück die bis ende des jahres
abgeschaltet werden sollen ob die an
bleiben weil die letzten sechs haben für
über zehn prozent der versorgung
beigetragen und ich glaube dass der
diskussionspunkt er ist streiten wir uns
über zehn jahre weiter atommüll und oder
streiten wir sie bei 15 grad ich finde
der druck der in der atom bewegung
ausgeübt wird warum ist das nicht für 15
grad der kohl also ich würde mich sofort
einstellen wenn kohle jetzt ausgeht und
wie das komplett transformieren kann
etwas anderes das geld das geld das wir
ausgegeben haben und die atomkraftwerke
runterzufahren die letzten jahre wo
hätte das ding kann alles so fragen die
eigentlich darauf zu gehen also müssen
wir deiner meinung nach einfach so ein
bisschen an sauren apfel beißen weiß
gerade in der liga da ich so viele
möglichkeiten ist ja gerade keine andere
lösung also sozusagen die 40 prozent
kohlekraft und die co2 tonnen die
dadurch ausgestoßen werden sind ja das
eigentliche problem mal 15 grad ist er
will also ist irreversibel aus der
atomkraft nicht nur zwei alternativen es
gibt ja nicht nur cool der unterton
kraft dass sie das nicht darf sich auf
das menschlich gibt sogar zuverlässiger
quellen gibt es wirklich atomkraft kohle
und ja sogar zweimal leider werden nicht
in island dafür aber und und solar und
solar und wind leider in deutschland ist
noch generell in der welt ist noch nicht
zuverlässig und es gibt nicht wirklich
speicherkapazitäten davon wir sagen
nicht dass sie sind schlecht wir sagen
einfach davon dass wir sind noch nicht
bereit komplett auf die avenue bus
umzusteigen
das halte ich für nicht zutreffend also
ich glaube tatsächlich ich bin ehrlicher
weise auch nicht per se der ansicht dass
man jetzt vom sicherheitsaspekt her
atomkraft als die schlechteste
technologie darstellen kann weil ich
glaube dass die kohlekraft wesentlich
mehr tote verursacht insofern aus
sicherheitsaspekten wenn man jetzt
wirklich nur die beiden alternativen
hätte würde ich auch gar nicht per se
gegen die atomkraft seien aber ich
glaube es ist einfach gar nicht die
beste möglichkeit die wir haben und es
löst eine eine abwägung aus die
gefährlich ist denn wenn wir auch
bestehende atomkraftwerke länger laufen
lassen wollen dann müssen wir sie auf
sicherheitsstandards und durch
instandhaltungsmaßnahmen auf level
bringen was sehr viel geld kostet und
dieses geld wird es für den ausbau der
erneuerbaren fähren insofern muss man
sich wirklich sehr sehr gut sehr gut
abwägen und verstehen dass das geld nur
einmal ausgeben werden kann die
energiewende wirklich zu schaffen ist
zum einen ein echtes commitment eine
komplette entschlossenheit notwendig das
heißt dass auch kein zurück mehr gibt
deshalb auch der atomausstieg verstehen
sollte warum zum zweiten braucht es wie
so oft auch schon diskutiert wird
wirklich einen drastischen abbau der
regulierung und der beschränkung wenn
man erneuerbare ausbauen möchte das ist
nicht zutreffend dass die atomkraft eine
gute ergänzung zur solar und wind ist
das ist die technisch nicht von daher
sollten andere technologien und andere
lösungen forciert werden und es sollte
durch die durch die geografische
diversifizierung von wind und solar über
ganz europa vielleicht sogar mit
nordafrika hinweg dadurch eine grundlast
erzeugt werden und eben nicht dadurch
dass man hat hofgang atomkraftwerk
gelaufen ist
sein schritt auch wenn das dazu gegangen
warum also ich denke dass man auf jeden
fall nicht nur gerne gebraucht wir
brauchen alle kohlenstoffarme
energiequellen und ich denke dass ge
lässt sich am besten machen wenn wir
alles auf einem ebenen spielfeld sich
entwickeln werde also das heißt wir
brauchen um möglichst schnell dahin zu
kommen brauchen wir ganz einfach alle
drei jetzt zumindest jetzt im moment so
lange wir nichts anderes haben ob das in
zehn zwanzig dreißig jahren eine andere
situation seien werde das kann ich nicht
sagen aber heute nach dem heutigen stand
ist es ist es nicht so dass wir alleine
mit solar und wind auskommen werden weil
die ganzen speicherkapazitäten haben wir
gar nicht wir haben sie nicht wir werden
gas und kohle brauchen und man hat ja
gesehen
in den letzten jahren und 20 jahren die
beste versicherung für die krone und
gasindustrie gewählt ist die ist dieser
100 prozent solar und wind ideologie
sage ich mal gewesen weil sie kunden
sich weiterhin profilieren als der große
freund der erneuerbaren energien
investors wurden jetzt schon ein paar
mal die fehlenden speicher möglichkeiten
gerade bei barren energien angesprochen
wie siehst du das ist das ein großes
brechen dann als das ist eine
herausforderung aber atomkraft ist keine
gute lösung atomkraftwerke sind darauf
ausgelegt also die deutschen
beispielsweise 400 mal in ihrem
lebenszyklus auf null zu fahren ungefähr
das heißt zehn mal pro jahr über 40
jahre damit kann ich nicht gut
modulieren und ich kann eben nicht in
einem stromnetz in dem ich 80 prozent
bis 2030 erneuerbare habe genau diese
wind veränderungen und die sonnen
veränderung ausgleichen dass es nicht
die richtigen ergänzungs technologien
darunter leidet darunter leidet der
betrieb das auch die wirtschaftlichkeit
weil atomkraftwerke haben so hohe
kapitalkosten dass ich sie eigentlich
permanent laufen lassen muss damit sie
von den bestellungen kosten also wie
viel cent pro kilowattstunde kostet das
überhaupt ansatzweise finanzierbar sind
aber so dass sie müssen wir ausgleichen
so
müssen wir auf die energie die wir
brauchen können machen wir das schritt
eins ist erstmal europäisch die
erneuerbaren ausbauen und nicht jedes
land für sich und eng vernetzen über den
ausbau der stromnetze denn ich habe wenn
ich gerade in der ostsee kein wind habe
ich welche der nordsee oder atlantik und
das gleiche gilt für die sonne also ein
sehr sehr hohen ausgleich und grundlast
grad erreicht man allein durch eine
geografische verkopplung das zweite sind
speicher das dritte sind ja für eine
gewisse weile auch noch peter
gaskraftwerke weil die einfach
modulieren können daher kann natur viele
rohstoffe im co2 für eine gewisse weile
ja weil die atomkraft das gar nicht
leisten kann die kann überhaupt nicht
der bereitstehenden ich habe ein
grundlastkraftwerke das funktioniert
nicht mehr zu landwind
man um wirklich die gleiche energie zur
wir sehen hier auch um sowie viel land
brauchen wir um so viel solar felder zu
bauen und solar wenn wir wissen im
vergleich oder so sind sagen wir jetzt
nicht aber solar verursacht 300 fach
mehr abfall alles atom wir können wir
können natürlich für die gleiche menge
produzierter energie produziert und das
ist schon so auf sein thema worauf wir
gern müssen wirken wir müssen nicht
immer so sagen auch grüne energie
bedeutet kein co2 alles so super wir
mussten auch so sah es sprechen über den
abfall von schwermetallen die so blei &
guba der aus dem solaranlagen heute ist
dein in solaranlagen kommt noch zum
beispiel japan heutzutage hat schon ein
problem in zukunft alle diese abfall von
solaranlagen zu deponieren also das ist
schon so auch seine große großes problem
eines muss ich noch mal sagen zu dem
thema genannten wir könnten europäisch
lösen aber die anderen europäischen
ländern machen eben nicht den deutschen
kurs wirklich isoliert in der ganzen
welt die klimakrise ist jetzt und ich in
zehn jahren aber der bau von neuen
atommeiler der daumen so lange und die
aktuellen meiler weiter laufen zu lassen
das heißt ich verliere uns gefährlich
weil einfach die ganze rohrleitungen
korrodieren irgendwann haben wir den gau
auch hierzulande und ich möchte nicht
warten das ist zu spät wäre jasmin was
sagst du dazu dass die klimakrise jetzt
und eben nicht in zehn jahren und der
bau aber lange dauert würdest du diese
diskussion werde einen reha blisch das
weckt einfügen also wie kann ihr der es
geht hier ganz so mobil ist muss falsch
ist wenn man sagt meiner meinung nach
könne sofort das ganze land pflastern
mit solarium geht es mir gar nicht
sondern es gibt frische gegebenheiten
das heißt wer regiert wer hat welche
pläne und wie geht das ausland so und
der kohleausstieg ist nicht auf ein
datum festgelegt das ist der schlimmste
skandal meiner meinung nach
energiepolitischen den letzten jahren
gegeben hat dass wir nicht wissen man
die kohle aus das ist für also sagen wir
wissen nicht ob wir uns nicht gerade
schaffen das würden wir nämlich dann
wissen das ist das viel wichtiger punkt
das heißt es gibt ganz schön debatte
darum was schön wäre sondern was
passiert und wenn wir ausfälle haben
kriegen wir trotzdem von den
französischen nach von atomstrom wir
kriegen aus polen auch kohlestrom und
wenn es vereinzelte ausfälle gibt und
wenn das in zukunft wenn wir jetzt
sozusagen kohle nicht reduzieren und die
erneuerbaren nicht so schnell ausgebaut
werden weil wir in deutschland stichwort
bürokratisierung ein riesiges leben
haben weil sich parteien und kommunen
sehr querstellen gegen bestimmte
maßnahmen
dann kommen wir damit nicht hinterher
auch wenn das geld da ist das heißt wir
gehen wir mit der situation um wenn wir
eine stromknappheit kommen wenn es
teurer wird obwohl wir alle wissen ja
und an deren stelle muss man noch sagen
dann ist doch notwendig druck auszuüben
und zu sagen doch es ist möglich jetzt
erneuerbare energien konsequent
auszubauen anstatt zu sagen aber hat
sich eine der letzten 20 jahren nun
kriegen es nicht so gut hin blöd
gelaufen okay dann lassen wir das und
machen atomstrom sind wir fast alles
doch jetzt seit 20 jahren ja nur sinn
wenn man 20 jahre massive 18 hier wir
sind jetzt dabei immer noch bei einer
co2-emission die fünf mal so hoch sind
wie frankreich was die elektrizität
angeht fünfmal so hoch und deutschland
werde vermutlich dort seien in zehn
jahren wenn es gut geht wo frankreich
schon vor 20 jahren gewesen ist das muss
man einfach aussehen also das heißt so
einfach ist es nicht man baut nur
erneuerbare energien aus ohne zu gucken
ob das diesen speicher bedarf gibt oder
nicht und wenn das wetter einfach nicht
so gut ist dann haben wir ein problem da
brauchen wir ein backup und im moment
ist dieser bei kohle und gas und wenn
jetzt das weitergeht mit dieser
gasknappheit heißt es dass der
kohleausstieg wird noch weiter in die
zukunft verlegt werden aber um hier auch
mal auf diese idee zu kommen von dass
sich der wind der an der ostsee fehlt
dann zum beispiel durch den atlantik
ausgleich auch in bezug auf die eu
taxonomie ist es einfach keine gute
strategie jetzt atom und gas auszubauen
das ist auch extrem klimaschädlich beide
wales überall erneuerbare energien
ausgebaut werden und dann müssen sich
länder vernetzen und müssen sich eben
gegenseitig mit erneuerbaren und nicht
gefährlichen technologie hinaus helfen
das wird jetzt irgendwie den klimawandel
krass nach vorne zu treiben wie wäre
denn das szenario wenn wir jetzt beim
planen bleiben und wir sagen ende 2022
ende diesen jahres geht das letzte
atomkraftwerk vom netz was passiert dann
das werde dann passieren dass wir noch
viel länger an kohle und gas gas hängen
bleiben und deswegen bin ich gegen die
aufnahme von gas in die taxonomie das
ist ganz klar das ist co2
emittieren und auch schädlich aber wie
die forschungseinrichtungen der
europäischen union auch fest gehalten
hat ist das kernige ist genauso der
gleichen ebene zu stellen wie solar und
wind beide haben vorteile beide haben
nachteile und das beste was wir tun
können ist alle kohlenstoffarme
energiequellen zusammen zu nutzen um den
klimawandel möglich schnell zu bremsen
und wenn wir das nicht schaffen kann ich
nur sagen ich hoffe dass die anderen das
kapiert haben und das tun er ist das
nicht eigentlich ein absolutes
totschlagargument gegen gas dass
atomkraft nicht also dich co2 frei ist
aber sehr viel co2 ärmer sollte das
nicht eindeutig dafür sprechen
ich sehe
weder kohle oder atom noch gas aber
irgendwas müssen wir gar nicht denn ist
aber es wäre nicht energieeffizient das
nicht nur gut und wir waren in derart
effizient da sein können wir unsere
unseren konsum wechseln und ich
engagiere mich für die umwelt nicht nur
ich will keine techno lösungen wir
müssten auch ein system change
hervorrufen das bedeutet wir müssen
anders leben anders konsumieren weil
einfach die rbs muss dann begrenzt sind
und dass sie sowohl der fall für uran
als auch für diversen fossilen energien
und möchte auch noch reinwerfen das zu
uns atomkraft ist auch nicht komplett
co2 frei insbesondere nicht wenn man den
gesamten zyklus mit berechnet zum
beispiel den uranbergbau mit rechner den
bau
und weiß auch nicht mal in den
offiziellen berechnungen drin ist zum
beispiel die co2 intensiv das thema
endlagerung sein wird wissen wir noch
nicht wohin ich sehe das wie ein
flugzeug russland aber ein ganz gutes
pflaster die gerne ausreden aber
wenn wir wie die regierung man im moment
wollen das tief lagern wollen da braucht
wieder sehr viel beton sehr viel co2
etwas hier werde beton so einfach ist es
eigentlich genau das ist die kernfrage
wohin mit dem atommüll wir haben
lösungen und es gibt länder die das
schon haben und die haben es auch
kostengünstig gemacht zum beispiel
finnland hatte ihrer lösung mit
zweieinhalb milliarden bis dreieinhalb
milliarden das habe ich verschiedene
zahlen gelesen aber die sind wesentlich
unter dem was hier immer wieder
behauptet wird mit mehrstelligen doppel
stelligen millionen zahlen hier in
deutschland das ist nicht der fall das
problem ist lösbar wenn nur der
politische wille und da komme ich
nochmal zurück und das war in
deutschland nicht der fall man hat dann
eine verbindung gesetzt zwischen wir
müssen ausstieg aussteigen sonst machen
wir bei der atommüll frage nicht mit das
war das problem gewesen deswegen sind
wir noch an der stelle wo wir wo wir vor
20 30 jahren waren mein herz schon seit
50 jahren dass man eine lösung für
atommüll hat nein ist es nicht die
diversen versuche das gegebene hat zum
beispiel in den usa beim vfb heißt das
in granit wurde das angebot da gab es
schon fädelt euro austritt von
radioaktivität bruder jonah plötzlich
messbare an der oberfläche nein es gibt
kein sicheres endlager tut mir leid dass
ihr sagt sie möchte keine kohle sie
möchte kein gas und sie möchte auch
keinen atomkraft was sagst du alina ist
das überhaupt realistisch also
meiner meinung nach ist es heutzutage
nicht realistisch also wir können jetzt
nicht ein leck oder mit der europas
haben weil keine ahnung im
februar einfach keine sonne scheint und
kein wind weht also idealistisch ich
verstehe warum ja so wir sollen
eigentlich auf
unsere konsum reduzieren aber wie sie
wohnen so in einem gesellschaft und wir
haben so
industriebedarf wirtschafts bedarf wo
man kann nicht einfach so idealistisch
reingehen wir haben uns mal ist das
realistisch in betracht also wo kommt
dieser bedarf her also ist es wirklich
notwendig dass so viel produziert wird
das so viel konsumiert wird und dann
muss man ganz klar sagen nein es ist
nicht notwendig also wir müssen einfach
anfangen dieses wachstums socken dogma
und dieses profitorientierte handeln zu
verändern hin zu einem füreinander
sorgen im handeln zu einem mitte also
ökologischem handeln anstatt diesen
planeten auszubeuten uns gegenseitig
auszubeuten und ja im prinzip ein
zerstörerisches gesellschaftssystem
aufrechtzuerhalten jasmin du bist ein
schritt zurück gegangen ja ich dieses
sollte und könnte geht mir ein bisschen
auf den keks und das ist das was sie
diese debatte immer wieder passiert weil
nein diese gesellschaft sich nicht zu
hundert prozent umdrehen nein es ist ein
klares nein es wird nicht passieren
dafür gibt es nicht genug bewegen dafür
gibt sich genug leute die so wählen und
ich kann auch sagen also selbst aus
hintergrundgesprächen mit hochrangigen
grünen die wissen dass es jetzt klappt
wird es ist nicht so dass man jetzt für
atom ist aber dass man das in der
öffentlichkeit sagen würde das ist schon
grad eine grenze und wenn wir die
politische landschaft in deutschland
komplett anschauen ist die eine hälfte
der wähler definitiv konservativ liberal
oder gar recht das heißt diese mehrheit
für den absoluten wandel der in einer
linken oder grünen ideologie gewünscht
ist egal ob das gut für noch nicht er
wird nicht passieren das heißt was
machen wir jetzt damit weil wir wissen
dass 15 grad kommt und das ist ja der
kondition wird zumindest zu 64 gerade
haben was ja eigentlich schön das war
das sehr selten passiert
wie schaffen wir denn dass es jetzt
passiert dass wir wissen wir können uns
erst mal versichern dass wir kohle
abschalten also ich glaube meine größte
angst ist weil wie gesagt diese atommüll
ist da er ist da und er wird es auch
noch ein paar jahre geben und
deutschland speziell ist fraglich werden
auch keinen neuen mehr gebaut werden da
geht es auch darum wir gehen mit dem eu
ausland um die werden weiterhin bauen
werden wir die partnerschaften haben
werden wir von denen strom beziehen wenn
es bei uns klappt wird wird es die
nächste regierung und jetzt umgebung
schaffen dass wir erneuerbare so
ausbauen dass uns darauf verlassen
können wenn diese und forschung
investieren dass wir sagen können die
speicherkapazitäten für solar sind
irgendwann da 2029 und ich glaube das
sind die fragen die uns beschäftigen
müssen erst das muss denn deiner meinung
nach jetzt konkret passieren weil wir
haben das ja jetzt ist jetzt schon immer
wieder aufgekommen dass wir schneller
mit den erneuerbaren energien voran
kommen weil es wurde ja schon oft genug
gesagt wir kommen nicht schnell genug
voran absolut und das ist mir auch
wichtig zu sagen die ziele die wir haben
80 prozent erneuerbare bis 2030 in
deutschland auch sehr hohe ziele eu-weit
die sind nicht unrealistisch die sind
auch jetzt noch zu schaffen sie sind
sehr ambitioniert nur ich habe die große
sorge dass wenn man jetzt auf einmal
dieses atomkraft thema auf macht nochmal
ein weiteres argument geliefert wird um
eben die die veränderung die notwendig
sind nicht zu tätigen und die
veränderung sind keinen großen es kostet
nicht viel geld es muss in deutschland
jetzt beispielsweise bundesweit
standardisiert werden wie man
solaranlagen windkraftwerk anmelden kann
das muss automatisiert erfolgen zum
beispiel über die bundesnetzagentur dass
nicht jedes jeder netzbetreiber in jeder
stadt selber entscheidet wie die
prozesse sind dass ein relativ einfache
entscheidungen zum zentralisieren und
zum entbürokratisieren und das wird dann
die die energiewende entfesseln und wir
sehen auch dass auch schon wir sehen das
in bestimmten segmenten und ich glaube
und denke schon dass eine pulle die
sendung jetzt da ist vielleicht nicht so
groß wie man sich die gewünscht hätte
aber eben doch dass da schritte kommen
von denen ich auch glaube dass sie
helfen dann trotzdem das ist ja bisher
passieren noch nicht so passiert dass
wir diese diskussion gerade mich führen
müssten ja ist das also eine frage des
politischen willens oder rob lowe s hat
der politische willen gefehlt wir haben
in den letzten 10 14 jahren keine keine
politische mehrheit dafür gehabt dass
wurden gesetze gemacht das
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz die novellen
dies in den letzten jahren gab hatten
sehr viele fallstricke die dafür gesorgt
haben dass auch junge unternehmen wie
unseres nicht in der geschwindigkeit
wachsen konnte wie es eigentlich vom
markt gewünscht ist und ich glaube schon
dass es relativ leicht zu entfesseln ist
und ich würde auch nochmal liegt es mir
schon wichtig auch widersprechen alle
anderen machen es anders das stimmt
nicht es gibt einzelne länder die auf
atomkraft setzen natürlich ist
frankreich prominent ist gibt im
baltikum in osteuropa einige länder aber
eigentlich ist das thema rein
marktwirtschaftlich an ganz vielen orten
auch tot es finden sich auch kaum
private investoren dafür dass ist neue
kraftwerk sind viel zu teuer und rechnen
sich nicht gegenüber den strompreisen an
der börse deshalb ist das nicht ein
einzel weg den wir gehen spanien italien
ganz viele burschen bei den erneuerbaren
massiv jasmin du hast es für ihn schon
mal kurz angesprochen dass da auch
vielen politikern zu tun hast dass du
auch weiß aus hintergrundgesprächen dass
leute zum beispiel von den grünen sagen
ja ehrlich gesagt würde das auch sinn
machen wenn man zum beispiel atomkraft
wieder in erwägung ziehen würde was
glaubst du denn ist da das problem also
geht es um festhalten an dem
atomausstieg und um glaubwürdigkeit oder
geht es tatsächlich um überzeugung woran
liegt es da ich glaube es ging man
überzeugung und jetzt ist es so
ideologie
basiert dass wir halt dieses problem
haben das ist dass man keine meinung
haben kann ohne automatisiert zu werden
und ich glaube dass das in der
bevölkerung prinzipiell in diese
diskussion nicht so angekommen ist wie
wir das jetzt gerade wollen weil es mich
sehr von oben herab ist und so
ideologisiert es das heißt sie ein
verbinden automatisch mit erneuerbaren
die grünen wollen uns ein windrad vor
die haustür ballern und die anderen
verbinden damit atomkraft uns die
regierung die cdu ist schuld dass wir
die klimakrise haben und abschaffen also
sozusagen diese zwei extreme die grünen
sind aus der anti-atom-bewegung mit
entstanden würdest du sagen die stehen
sich jetzt in ihrer jetzigen position
mit ihrer wie du gesagt hast und nicht
zu zitieren ideologie im weg nein ich
glaube die sind einfach das ist dass der
unterricht zwischen aktivistischen
bewegungen klimabewegung und realpolitik
wenn man in einer regierungsebene
ankommen wie die grünen ist jetzt final
nicht in der schröder ära sind sondern
jetzt mit der fdp und der spd merkt man
einfach welche kompromisse man eingehen
muss wenn es bestimmte schlimme
szenarien gibt es was denkt ihr dann
sollten sich die parteien dieser frage
atomkraft ja oder nein noch mal stellen
bevor ende 2022 die letzten
atomkraftwerke in deutschland vom netz
geben schreibt es mal in die kommentare
ja du bist gerade einen schritt auf
jasmin zugegangen wie so genau weil
gerade diese also bei den punkt einmal
unterschied von sozialen bewegungen und
von parteipolitik und da eben
kompromisse gemacht werden müssen und
auch so ein punkt wir brauchen eine
große veränderungen wollte ich noch mal
stark machen dass ich der meinung bin
dass ein großer wandel möglich ist und
dass der vor allem von der straße kommt
oder dass auch diese idee wir müssen
einfach wir müssen profitorientiert hat
und wir müssen ausbeutung als grundlage
von unserer gesellschaft überdenken und
müssen wir verändern
sowohl um soziale krisen als auch
ökologische krise aufzuhalten und zu
stoppen das hätten sich auch mütter
atomkraftwerke zur zeit das möchte man
ganz klar sagen es gibt schon die ein
klima bewegung es gibt auch menschen die
für atomkraft auf die straße gehen also
es gibt auch diese berühmte szene auf
der after der preise fischer dem niveau
einer atomkraft aktivistin die dafür ist
die mit reis fischer angst also
demonstrieren wollte wurde er weggezerrt
und ausgebuht wohl auch wieder sagen
muss was gibt es da für hierarchien und
wie es unser miteinander in der
lösungsfindung 15 gratis und sah wie
sehr du nicht gehst du da ein klein
wenig schritt auf jasmin zu nur in
diesem punkt also ich würd sagen
ich habe gerade so ein bisschen ich habe
gerade gelegt weil ich sagen würde ja
ich finde die art und weise miteinander
umgehen ist auf jeden fall ein großer
punkt wie gehen wir zwischenmenschliche
miteinander oben wollen wir wirklich in
konkurrenz um miteinander stehen um die
meisten profit zu machen weil das
zerstört diesen kanälen und das zerstört
irgendwo auch uns finde ich sehr sehr
schön und sehr idealistisch verstehen ja
zu einer krise wir sehr was jetzt
passiert in der ukraine mit mustern wir
müssen nicht vergessen dass deutschland
zum beispiel gas 30 aus russland bekommt
jetzt haben wir gehört dass scholz hat
gesagt wieso nord nord stream zwei
aufhalten jetzt stehen wir vor einer
energiekrise jetzt können wenn ihr jetzt
können wir schon reden wie es eigentlich
in zehn jahre sich entwickeln soll aber
was ist war soll jetzt ein paar jahren
passieren ich meine wenn jetzt die
atomkraftwerke jetzt also alle
ausgeschaltet werden woher kommt jetzt
gas also das bedeutet wie möglich aber
hilft uns mittag und kohle und gas
abhängen werden von gas es jetzt
schwierig weil wir gesagt wieder so
diese jetzt ganz politische frage auch
und wir weiter mit russland verhandeln
oder so aber wir brauchen das gas ja
auch vor allem als wir brauchen es zum
teil für strom aber wir brauchen es ja
vor allem für prozesswärme
industrieprozessen und wir brauchen es
zum heizen betrag entrichtet die
atomkraft wenn wir jetzt aber die
atomkraftwerke nicht ausschalten dann
können wir diese energie noch nutzen und
ein bisschen weit und weit von dieser
import von gas gehen ja er ist einer von
größte importeur auf und gas sind ist
trotzdem den punkt das gas gerade in der
aktuellen situation auch wenn man mit
ländern wie russland zusammenarbeitet
eine politische sackgasse werden könnte
und auch wenn man perspektivisch in den
nächsten zehn 20 30 40 jahre guckt dann
ist ja klar wir werden immer mehr strom
brauchen also gerade kommen wir in eine
situation wo man so ist so ok da kann
jemand einfach sagen egal krieg kein
strom also 100% ich glaube die idee dass
jetzt importiertes pipelinegas und auch
überhaupt gab es für uns eine tragende
säule oder die tragende säule in dem
energiemix sein sollte die habe ich
nicht ich glaube dass gazprom ist ja vor
allem in wärme und und auch industrie
problem ist ja wenn man sich den
strommix anschaut sind gaskraftwerke
wegen ihrer flexibilität wichtig aber
nicht wegen dem wegen der menge die sie
liefern da spielen sie eine eher
untergeordnete
um die frage mit der zusammenarbeit mit
russland
also das ist für mich eine ganz andere
debatte weil da hilft die atomkraft
nicht dass ich damit sagen also wenn ich
kann die antwort darauf trotzdem das hat
die frage also glaube ich klar ja ich
glaube dass wir beim gas schon viel
früher hätten diversifizieren müssen und
dann sukzessive natürlich gab es auch
durch wasserstoff ersetzen müssen aber
ich glaube schon dass wir flüssiggas
brauchen und bereit sein müssen dafür
ein bisschen preis zu zahlen wir haben
uns bisher politisch auch damals
fukushima zu der zeit habe ich auch mit
einigen energieunternehmen zu tun gehabt
in meinem job als unternehmensberater
der waren damals die politischen
entscheidung wir setzen voll auf das
pipeline gas und das halte ich für ein
fehler ich glaube schon dass man
diversifizierten gasimport braucht bis
wir irgendwann kein gas mehr brauchen
sowohl in der wärme weil wir auf
wärmepumpen sind und anderen
technologien als auch beim strom selbst
aber ich glaube nicht dass wir auf gas
werden verzichten können und
atomkraftwerke werden uns dabei nicht
helfen für die nächsten ich sag mal zehn
15 jahre insofern brauchen wir sowieso
gas und müssen das problem anders lösen
wir sagen ja natürlich auch noch gas und
tatsächlich so wir brauchen die ganze
sowie verschiedene energiequellen um
wirklich unser netzwerk stabil zu lassen
und damit eine steigende
so in deutschland steigt ständig
energiekonsum und ich meine das ist
wirklich einfach unmöglich jetzt einfach
zu sagen hey wir schalten jetzt
atomkraftwerke und dann werden nur auf
den die grüne energie aufsteigers wird
jetzt nicht in die nächsten 15 20 jahren
passieren es einfach gibt es keine
möglichkeit wirklich auf grüne energie
umzusteigen das bedeutet wir brauchen ab
ob die lösung
ich bin wo ich einfach dumm bin ist das
ist eine sackgasse wo ich einverstanden
ist die politik muss handeln und alles
zu viel zu träge egal welche politische
entscheidungen trifft bei der
erneuerbaren geht es viel zu träge wir
sind an einem punkt wo wir politische
entscheidung treffen müssen wenn
getroffen werden dann will ich die da
die gegen die atomkraft getroffen wenn
diese das geld nicht in diesem
greenwashing in dieser atomenergie geht
sondern da wo es auch richtig sinnvoll
investiert wird weil wir treffen
entscheidungen in einer geopolitisch
instabile lage und dann komme ich auf
russland zurück weil auch die verbindung
zum militär super ist also das
geopolitisch ist einfach ein
kochtopf was möglicherweise mit dem
druck irgendwann explodieren wird
atomkraft kann dann nicht dass sie zu
gefährlich wickeln doch nicht spielen
mit atomkraft wir haben glaube ich alles
uns allen klar geworden dass dieses
thema extrem komplexes wir haben über
die gefahren gesprochen über klima und
generationengerechtigkeit über globale
ungerechtigkeit über politische
abhängigkeit deswegen lass uns jetzt zum
abschluss nochmal bei der bei der
sozialen lösungen für dieses thema
bleiben ist ein atomenergie für uns alle
am günstigsten nein ich sage dieser weg
mit nur 100 prozent erneuerbare energien
das ist das problem
erneuerbare energien sind nicht schlecht
wir brauchen solar wir brauchen wind
aber das problem was wir in deutschland
hatten dass wir am anfang zumindest 890
als dieser energiewende eingeleitet
worden ist ging es ja gar nicht um klima
es ging um aus der atom aus der
atomenergie auszusteigen
und das hat jetzt dazu geführt dass wir
im prinzip nur
atom durch kohle ersetzt oder atom durch
ich sag mal erneuerbare energien ersetzt
haben wären kohle und gas weiter unter
weiter laufen konnten erste du hattest
das vorhin schon mal mit den
quasi mit den kosten angesprochen wie
siehst du das denn wäre atomkraft eine
lösung eine sozial gerechte lösung für
für die strom frage über die nächsten
fünf jahre hinaus nein und das ist
wirklich das mir auch der wichtigste
punkt ich gucke auch auf das thema
energie auch wenn ich selber so lange
die unternehmer bin sehr nüchtern und
und als volkswirt und es ist so ein
abgeschriebenes atomkraftwerk was da
steht seit 30 jahren ja das produziert
strom für 3 cent je kilowattstunde das
ist günstig aber nur solange ich das
nicht modernisieren muss oder neu bauen
muss ein neu gebautes kernkraftwerke
oder ein aufwändig modernisiert ist da
bin ich bei zwölf bis zwanzig cent
alleine holzteile also börsenpreis plus
die ganzen umladen wenn wir das sozial
gerecht sein wollen dann müssen wir die
umlagen reduzieren wird jetzt ja
teilweise gemacht da müssen wir auf
erneuerbare setzen die sind am
günstigsten und dann müssen wir
letztlich also wenn wir gucken gerade
frankreich hat im moment höhere
börsenpreise strom als deutschland
bereits und wurde seit wochen das hat
nix mit das hat mir den fertigungskosten
grenzkosten thema und da ist einfach
atomkraft nicht die lösung es ist nicht
können also gerade was die kosten angeht
muss ich mir wirklich widersprechen das
ist ja wirklich eine wieder ein
deutscher tunnelblick war muss ich sagen
wenn man internationale vergleiche sieht
und das hängt natürlich damit zusammen
wie man das aus rechnet läuft ein
kernkraftwerk nur 35 jahren wie in
deutschland oder 60 oder 80 jahren wie
die neuen geplant werden dann sieht die
rechnung komplett anders aus wir könnten
detailliert ihn alle diese berechnungen
gehen was die entstehungskosten gehen
und was die kosten für die endlagerung
angehen dass es sind alles mieten die
wir seit 30 40 jahren hören wir sollten
uns wirklich mit den fakten wie sie
heute existieren mit der heutigen stand
mit dem heutigen stand der technik uns
auseinandersetzen und die sieht völlig
anders aus das musste ich auch selber
lernen ich glaube es ist jetzt der
richtige zeitpunkt um zumindest mal zu
versuchen zu den kompromissen zu kommen
und welche zu finden das ganze läuft so
ab ich habe einen kompromissvorschlag an
euch und zudem könnt ihr euch gleich
positionieren wir sagen was ihr davon
denkt und dann habt ihr zeit auf eurem
fällt um die köpfe zusammenzustecken und
ein kompromissvorschlag an die andere
seite zuwenden ok kommen wir zu einem
kompromissvorschlag für euch was klar
geworden ist wir kommen nicht drum herum
in den ein oder anderen saugen apfel zu
beißen zumindest auf dem weg zu den
erneuerbaren energien wir müssen uns
öffnen auch in deutschland auch mit der
geschichte unserer anti-atom-bewegung in
deutschland für einen ergebnisoffenen
diskurs über das ja oder nein zumindest
noch mal darüber zu sprechen da könnt
ihr es gerne noch mal einen schritt auf
mich zu gehen stehen bleiben oder wie du
dich gerade zurück giggs ist hier ja
stimmt mir zu tun hat sich zurück bewegt
warum es sich jetzt zeit dass die
politik handelt es ist nicht mehr zeit
rumzueiern bin ich dafür oder dagegen
die argumente sind alle auf dem tisch
wir haben uns entschieden wir sind gegen
die atomkraft deutschland hat auch einen
teilausstieg beschlossen das eine gute
sache auch wenn er nicht vollständig ist
wegen der brennstoff produktion in
lingen und gronau und das muss so
weitergehen ich will es nicht mehr den
moment reden wir darüber ich denke auch
aus pragmatismus wird macht es ist es
wäre es fatal wahrscheinlich sogar die
diskussion noch mal auf zu machen weil
sie ablenkt von den handlungs aufgaben
deshalb würde ich sie nicht aufmachen
sondern wenn überhaupt ja dann würde ich
sagen es sind jetzt drei kraftwerke am
noch am netz dann sollen halt die
bundesnetzagentur sagen welche drei
kohlemeiler sie raus nimmt und dafür
sagen dafür lassen wir die drei lkws
noch drei jahre laufen dafür sollte man
aus meiner sicht eine breite debatte
mehr die entscheidung muss trotzdem noch
mal darüber gesprochen und das überhaupt
noch mein erwägungen
keine ergebnisoffene diskussion das wäre
eine ganz spitze diskussion die die
frage hätte sollen wir jetzt kohlemeiler
xyz rausnehmen um jetzt zehn prozent co2
herunterzufahren sofort und dafür die
noch zwei oder drei jahre laufen lassen
dass wenn eine sehr spitze diskussion
eine ergebnisoffene diskussion gibt es
neue erkenntnisse und so weiter wird uns
massiv ablenken wir sehen ja wie lange
wir brauchen
und um überhaupt ins handel zukommen
lassen kann ganz kurz ersten warum es
zum schutz rück gegangen und weil es
hier nicht darum geht dass wir die
komplette diskussion noch einmal
aufrollen aber zu sagen was wenn wir
diese debatte auch machen wir vom
kernproblem ablängen ist halt auch
falsch weil es geht darum dass man sagt
das wichtigste das 105 grad und kohle
ist das problem das heißt diese nischen
debatte atom ist auch ein hinweis darauf
dass 105 grad durch kohle
gelöst werden müssen also das ist ein
teil des anteils zum besten wenn man
alle mit einbezieht das ist nämlich
nicht nur eine grüne perspektive sondern
die gesamte perspektive braucht auch
diesen atom diskussionspunkt deswegen
werde ich euch jetzt kurz einmal die
köpfe zusammenstecken lassen auf jedem
feld und ihr könnt euch jetzt ein
kompromissvorschlag für die andere seite
überlegen und versuchen wir die anderen
überzeugen könnt einen schritt auf uns
zuzugehen mal gucken ob das klappt
sie tun somit kann ich ihnen sagen kann
ich ihnen sagen was wir tun sollen weil
wie ist das denn mit den erneuerbaren
also wie schnell kann s ausgebaut werden
okay wir merken das thema ist wahnsinnig
komplexes muss super viel bedacht werden
wenn man sich entweder für oder gegen
atomenergie entscheidet und hier werden
gerade fleißig kompromisse sich überlegt
was ist denn euer kompromiss nachdem wir
diese sendung hier geschaut habt
schreibt gerne mal an die kommentare das
heißt wir werden jetzt nicht schon von
kohle in 225 aufzuschalten keine
einmischung ins eu-ausland das beispiel
von olympus überhaupt genau dann würde
ich sagen ich fange an mit eurem
kompromissvorschlag mit dem gelben fällt
was habt ihr euch überlegt
also wir haben festgestellt dass
herrscht einigkeit darin dass wir ein
gemeinwohlorientiertes
gesellschaftssystem bräuchten und dass
wir alle die klimakrise aufhalten
möchten und deswegen ist unser vorschlag
immer noch erneuerbare energien ausbauen
ein gemeinwohlorientiertes
gesellschaftssystem und energiesysteme
und das energiesystem vergesellschaften
ihr könnt also jetzt gerne ein schritt
auf das andere feld zu gehen stehen
bleiben einen schritt nach hinten gehen
der erste teil wäre okay aber wir müssen
zumindest die drei und ich würde sogar
sagen sechs kernkraftwerke wenn wir sie
wieder in stand bringen können laufen
lassen bis wir zu dem zeitpunkt gekommen
sind wo andere optionen besser sind hast
du das auch so nicht für den ansatz also
prinzipiell ich finde dass der
kompromiss sehr viel idealismus ist bis
auf eine sache die verstaatlichungen
prinzipiell ja in dem rahmen lebens
möglich ist in der politischen
gegebenheit ist ja nicht was das überall
in jedem bundesland einfach so easy zur
diskussion steht dh
prinzipiell ja aber nur da wo es auch
politisch so möglich ist je nachdem wo
sich dafür mehrheiten finden und wo so
gewählt wird dass die politischen
akteure so handeln alina was denkst du
ja also ich
theoretisch würde ich unterschreiben
aber praktisch sicher dass es kein
wirklich praktische
art von kompromiss was wird jetzt in den
nächsten fünf jahren uns kommt passieren
würde ich euch jetzt gerne um euren
kompromissvorschlag bitten
unser ist ein bisschen also der lehnt
sich noch mal an dieser debatte um die
drei laufenden an
es geht erstens darum dass die drei
laufen dürfen solange und der jeweilige
prozentsatz den kohle verursacht
zurückgefahren wird das heißt das was
diese drei akw s weiterhin produzieren
würden je nachdem wie die erneuerbaren
aufholen dass meine kohle einzusparen
und das ist ein gesetztes ziel gipfel
ein co2 ausstieg finanziell
dass man weiß dass in dem er aus dass
man da aussteigen was das geld weil wir
auch eben über arbeitsplätze gesprochen
haben reinvestiert wird so dass die alle
menschen die in der kohle energie
arbeiten früh abgesetzt werden können
versichert also da geht es ja auch um
arbeitsplätze und soziale absicherungen
dass dieser transfer in die andere
energiebranche passiert und dass wir
sozusagen uns trotzdem mit diesen
atomkraftwerken die laufen noch etwas
absichern bis diese nicht mehr instand
gehalten werden können okay was sagt ihr
geht er einen schritt auf die andere
seite zu
zwei zentimeter ernesto ja das waren
auch sehr viele aspekte jetzt drin wo
viele jetzt auch nicht alles verarbeiten
können aber viele für mich nicht sehr
sinnvoll plausibel klang gerade dieses
thema transferleistung so ich glaube da
ist mehr als genug gemacht auch im
verhältnis zur größe der der
kohlebranche ich glaube dass nicht das
thema wie gesagt aus meiner sicht diese
drei kraftwerke zu tauschen für zwei bis
drei jahre sofern das überhaupt
praktikabel ist aber mit für mich aus
meiner sicht zwei bis drei jahre und zu
sagen dafür schalten wir sofort in
gleichem maße cola um jetzt einen großen
co2 effekt zu haben jetzt in 22 und 23
das ist das einzige was ich für sinnvoll
halte ich finde das also diese debatte
bei mir auch darüber gesprochen haben
wie präsentes thema sein sollte und wir
auch darüber gesprochen das heißt zwar
sehr viel reflexion über die debatte in
der debatte das hat mir gut gefallen
und ich immer sehr gern als realistin
ich weiß auch dass eine komfortzone ist
aber auch einerseits mein pessimismus
ist und ich glaube da nochmal immer
wieder dieses anstoßen von es gibt
dieses ideal und die halle kann man
umsetzen politische kraft gibt dem
entgegenzusetzen was man selber glaubt
und das manchmal sozusagen diesen
positiven gedanken das ist könnte
zuzulassen in der eigenen bewertung
das fand ich ganz gut ich glaube dass
ich trotzdem realistisch bleiben werde
aber dass immer wieder mitzunehmen und
das ist noch mal dazu zu stoßen und
vielleicht mit etwas mehr elan in die
nächste debatte zu gehen das könnte so
für mich persönlich mitnehmen dazu kann
ich nur sagen ich bin auf jeden fall die
juristin irgendwie uns beiden oder auch
generell ein realistischer mensch und
glaube auch dass es das in diesen
debatten auf jeden fall auch braucht
genauso wie es auch zum beispiel in form
von dir menschen braucht die ganz klar
sagen okay so sieht politisch aus und
das und das sind dicht also sind bis zu
der zustand in dem wir uns befinden und
ich glaube da ist es auch für wertvoll
daneben zusammenzukommen und eben
realistin und realistischen zu haben und
dann gemeinsam zu schauen okay was
könnte unser idealistisches ziel sein
oder was ist es und wie können wir da
irgendwie im hier und jetzt hinkommen
ich danke euch trotzdem vielmals für die
diskussion wirklich das hat sehr sehr
viel spaß gemacht und ich wünsche euch
noch einen schönen abend ein bisschen
wenn euch diese folge 13 fragen gefallen
hat dann das doch hier gerne ein abo für
den kanal da ich hier oben gibt es ein
weiteres video von 13 fragen und hier
unten ein weiteres video zum thema